it may not look like much but that is
one of the most important archaeological
sites in western europe when i say it's
prehistoric i mean that literally the
ruins that are buried here at ness of
brodgar are from around 5 000 years ago
when writing hadn't really been invented
and this
this is an old worn out tyre and today a
team of volunteers are putting 500 of
these
on top of that the nasa broadca is a
huge neolithic complex discovered in
2002 when we did geophysics across this
area despite the size of the trenches
this only covers approximately 10
percent of the site
uh it is massive it has a place of
gathering 5000 years ago we can envisage
hundreds of people coming here neolithic
society wasn't a kind of static society
and through the thousand years of the
nest was in use we see those changes
reflected in the architecture what the
nasa broadcast unlocked for
archaeologists is a huge range of
information we have many
new discoveries new types of discoveries
at the nasa broadcast the preservation
is quite remarkable
under nine inches of topsoil we have
neolithic walls standing and this is
because this field has never ever been
deeply plowed
the reason for the tyres and the plastic
underneath is a bit more obvious when
you know where we are the orkney islands
off the northern tip of scotland
the weather here can be brutal sure it's
nice today the temperature's usually
mild we're at the end of the gulf stream
here so it rarely gets too hot or too
cold but we're next to the ocean the
wind is harsh and fast and it blows in
salt spray the trouble with exposing the
past is that uh well you're exposing the
past
as soon as it's re-exposed to the air
water can start getting into the very
fine laminations in the building stone
and literally you'd see these walls
start to crumble at the end of each
season we cover the site with layers of
plastic then to hold all those covers in
place all these hundreds of tires i used
to live at the top of the hill just
behind us where we recorded once a gust
of over 120 miles an hour
and after some of the big storms we have
in the winter despite our best efforts
sometimes you'll come back to site in
the corner of the polythene and some of
the tyres will have actually been moved
by the wind the old tyres are a
practical solution they're free they're
heavy but they can be moved fairly
easily and they're just soft enough not
to cause damage when they're on top of
the plastic shooting they look ugly
they're going to disappoint any visitors
for the next few months but it means the
site is still going to be there intact
when spring comes and archaeology can
start again we have to protect it we
have to do the to the best our abilities
because these walls have stood for over
5000 years and it's a top priority for
us to hopefully keep them there and keep
them in prime condition for the next
5000 years
gonna be honest i didn't actually need
the tyre there they just gave me one so
i could be out of the way of the
volunteers who are doing the actual hard
work
you